Okay.
Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday, Monday morning podcast and
ahhh
just checking in on you today.
Hey, what's going on? How are you? It's a really Thursday afternoon. Um,
I forgot it was Thursday.
I've been so fucking busy doing something that I'm not allowed to announce yet.
And Wink, wink, wink, wink, wake, wake, wake, wink. Um,
for whatever fucking reason. And uh, my phone, shit, the bed, my phone, shit,
the bed, my fucking red, um, phone shit, the bed.
And uh, so I had to go over to Verizon
and uh, see what the fuck was wrong with.
It turns out when I went to all Canada,
none of our teams are in the playoffs, but we still have so up,
let's all start up fucking riot. When I went up there,
I didn't have a cell phone plan,
so Verizon just decided out of the fucking moo too.
Um, I dunno,
just put some sort of block on the things so I wouldn't get some sort of extra
charges, which I had already resigned myself to getting. I'm just like, fuck it.
I'm not getting the plan. I'm up here for three, four days.
I'll have a big cell phone bill. What do I give a fuck? I don't give a shit.
You want me to write some numbers on a piece of paper and then you stick it in
the thing and then the numbers show up on the screen. I mean,
that's how much what money means to me. To me at this fucking point,
it's just like, well,
well what do you want me to write on the little piece of paper?
Who gives a fuck? We put a smiley face in the Zeros. That's all we're doing.
None of us has anything of value.
We just got a bunch of stuff in a fucking hell out. Jesus. Bill,
you're going down this road. I am. I am going down this road.
How many people do you know have any think a fucking piece of silver,
some gold, whatever happened to us. We used to be gentlemen, right?
Our wenches stayed home.
We rode around on a donkey with our curly cued mustaches.
We had a little Satchel, a fucking gold or some shit, right?
Then some bandits would come along and they'd take it from you, right?
All dressed in green with the fucking, you know,
leotards on all that Robin Hood Shit. Right.
Then there was some brought up in the tower. All of that is gone. It's all gone.
No. Now you work all week. They give you a little piece of paper.
It's got some numbers on it.
You stick it into the ATM and then the numbers show up, right? He goes, hey,
you owe me some money. I'll write some numbers on fucking piece of paper.
You Go, all right, thank you.
You know it all works until it doesn't. And then what do you get here?
It's going to happen. You're not going to have anything. So anyways. Yeah.
So I don't give a fuck. And what, what do I give a big cell phone bill?
What do I give a shit? If it's more numbers on a piece of paper, it's not
better.
I guess at the end of the day it is where something, but I just, I don't give a
about a high cell phone bill and I don't give a shit about sky miles.
I just don't give a fuck. You know what I mean?
You don't like when you have some miles with somebody and they go, oh you,
you better use these. You better use are they're gonna expire.
I always call them up. You Ca. Yeah. Well you know you can keep them.
I don't need you fucking miles or I take them now. I don't give a shit.
Stop threatening me with your stupid fucking miles by now.
If I need a plane ticket, I'll buy one.
Anything to not have to go into your fucking website and figure out where I can
fly with my so called free miles already paid for it. They're not free.
You can't, Oh God, I'm in a mood. So anyways,
so my phone didn't fucking work. So whenever,
so I went up there and they put a block on it so I wouldn't,
I have to write a bigger number on a piece of paper and send it to them so they
can stick it in their ATM machine. And, uh,
when I came back it was still blocked. So I went over to the Verizon place,
turned out the person who helped me out was a fucking lesson. Right.
And he's trying to help me fix the phone or what's killing me is his company did
the thing to my phone that's now made my phone fucked up and they can't figure
out how to undo it. And, uh, you know,
I tried as long as I could to keep my cool. I didn't flip out that,
but I dropped a couple of f bumps. I'm glad he told me that, you know,
he was a listener of the podcast because, you know,
if he didn't say that then I just would have been, you know,
I wouldn't have been on my best behavior and I would have said fuck a lot more.
Um, it took me two trips over there cause then they were like, all right,
well I think we fixed it. This is like an hour later.
I think we fixed it and uh, it should, you know,
reboot by tomorrow morning. So I was like, alright, fine. You know,
I get back to the office, I can't fucking, you know,
I go to text my lovely wife, it's not going through. I'm like, what the fuck?
So I saw Ellen, maybe I'll call her, cause I wanted him to take the, uh,
the capital's against the fucking floor.
I wanted to tape the game, you know, and uh,
I went to call up and it just, I called her number and it just goes,
welcome to Verizon.
Please enter your last four digits of your social security number.
Please enter this by pressing one.
You agree to a two year contract with Verizon.
If you come out early, you will yellow. It's upon. I'm like,
what the fuck is this? So I uh,
I had ended up having to go back to the fucking place and um,
this other guy got on and he figured out what the fuck was wrong with this and
now my phone is fine. So I've just, I've had one of those fucking day.
So when I was in there I was just thinking, you know, and I was just like,
you know, my can't listen to my music. And they were like,
oh that's cause it's on the cloud. And I was like,
I never wanted to be on the cloud. I don't want to be on that fucking thing.
I don't want you guys seeing what the fuck I'm doing. Leave me alone.
I keep opting out of that fucking thing. But every time I reboot my phone,
it just fucking automatically starts back up or some shit.
You fucking nosy nerdy cunts.
Yeah.
They always sit like act on like to do when you will fucking favor. You know,
someone was telling me that,
that that shit about them sharing your private information. I,
which I've said the entire fucking time that they should get your permission
first. And certainly if they go and resell it, you ought to get a cut of it,
right? I mean, it's your personal information too.
They act as a broker of shouldn't you get a fee?
I guess that's in the Supreme Court. That's what somebody told me.
He wasn't a lawyer and I can even remember who it was. Um,
so anyways, so as I'm sitting there is time is time's going by.
I started looking at the flip phones and I was like, Oh man,
I love these things. Flip loans, what great. You know,
a little fucking size of a hockey but not even the size of a hockey puck right
in your pocket. You know what I mean?
But what killed me was they all had a camera on them,
which I don't fucking like,
and I didn't have time to ask the guy who's going to do,
you just have a flip phone that has no fucking camera on it.
And maybe I'll go back to this and I asked the other guy asked the other guy,
these are all young guys, right? Born in the 90s, right? So I'm like,
do they still sell, sell iPods? And he's like, yeah,
apple store best buy or whatever. So I say, fuck it.
I'll just put all my music on the fucking my iPod,
right. And then I'll just get one of these flip phones.
And I was really trying to think what the fuck I would be missing out on.
It would take me longer to text my pictures wouldn't be as good.
Who gives a fuck? My video would be as good. Who gives a fuck and a,
you know what the deal breaker was? The GPS system.
I don't want to go back to m and a Tom. I still have a Thomas Guide,
my fucking Prius. I don't want to have to go back to looking up shit. I mean,
as much as I would like to use my brain to do that again,
out of all the things that they've made easier, um, I think, uh,
you know, I got gotta give it up as much as, as epic as a curmudgeon,
that I am the a, the fucking thing telling you where to go is great.
You know,
even though I've probably already pitched about it on the podcast and that was
sort of the deal breaker, I was like, well I got, I got to have one of those.
Right. I at least got to have that.
I don't want to go back to looking at fucking maps and shit, you know,
although I could figure it out, most of it, I dunno.
I think what would end up happening is not the social aspect of it would be the
business aspect. I don't do the Uber thing,
so I wouldn't be missing out on that.
And I don't fucking order food that way, do I?
No, I don't, I don't even know what the fuck I have it flow.
Is this still a podcast? Is it just me? Just fucking boy.
I've always babble anyways. Um, yeah,
I've had a fucking brutal week, man. I lost my fucking shit.
Like my temper has never been worse. It's never been worse. I, I,
I need to, uh, I need to fucking relax.
Um, I was working all day and all I wanted was some spaghetti and meatballs.
I got this fucking Italian joint. They make the homemade noodles,
the meatballs are fucking damn good, you know? And I just went a craving for it.
I'm like, I'm fucking getting that right.
So I get home and I say to my lovely wife, I go, Hey, can you,
can you fucking hit the app thing that gets the person to go pick up your food?
And we'll once again, you know,
once again have faith that this person outside of the food industry is not going
to do anything to this food. You know? Have you seen that thing?
The guy in the fucking elevator eating some shit off the top of the pizza.
And of course we call the restaurant. They don't do it.
Postmate it can you postmate the fucking thing and they're like, oh,
we don't do that over here. We're a real restaurant. So I'm like, all right,
well we put in the order and my wife wanted some white fish.
I'm going to get to spaghetti.
So I fucking drive over there and jam pack with people. I go, yeah,
hey, a pickup order.
She goes, oh, is that for this spaghetti in a white fish? I was like, yeah,
it was. She's like, oh, we ran out of fish.
So I didn't put it in. And did you still want the spaghetti?
Yeah, and I swear to God, man,
it's like we fucking call 10 minutes ago,
it took you 10 minutes to figure out you were out of fish. I just said,
you know what, hang on a second.
Because I knew I was going to snap and I just walked out of the restaurant and
the second I got outside I just started cock sucking motherfucker.
The fuck does it take the fucking God damn fucking fuck is we get just flipping
out. Right? Was it screaming? Just cook, suck that type of shit right. Far Away.
You'd think I was speaking German,
I should [inaudible] cock sucking motherfucker. Right.
And I heard these two people, those people are eating outside.
They started laughing at me, right?
And I didn't give a shit and I just kept him on a fucking and then got my Prius
and just glided away. Just whoosh.
Made a complete and utter fucking full of myself.
Complete and utter fucking fool of myself. And um, okay. You know,
I go to these great periods. It's almost like my cigar smoking.
I just go to this great periods where I'm just not, I got it under control,
I got it under control and then it just slowly, you know,
spins out of control. And right now, you know, I'm not smoking a lot.
I'm drinking a little bit, but nothing crazy.
I think I have everything under control and just something has to,
something's got to give. You know what I mean? It's like you give up smoking,
you eat like a fucking pig, you know? I don't know. You start working out.
There's always something. Just got to balance it out.
I these these fucking people that are nothing but do gooders. I mean,
I don't know. Maybe they are robots. I don't know what the, what they are.
Well maybe they just never exposed themselves to fun shit.
But for the love of God, I can't do it.
I cannot 100% just be a decent human being.
I don't think it's a, I don't think it's possible. I have too much free time.
Maybe that's what it is. I mean,
I'm just a piece of shit and I'm looking for an excuse. I don't fucking know.
But, um, anyways,
I haven't been able to work out as much as I want to.
I think that Burns off a lot of the bullshit. But, uh, anyway,
speaking of which, the gym, the gym, the gym, the jumps getting a,
I get the floor put in Friday, it's a three day process.
This epoxy floor, it's sort of the A, they call it a lob, the lava flow.
It's,
it's really fucking cool looking or it's going to look out of style in fucking
three days. I don't know what, but uh,
I did go with the gray was sort of a black blackish tinge to it,
so I Nice muted fucking color and uh,
Nia told me to get a mirror in there, you know,
cause she wants to look at her form when she's doing whatever the hell she's
doing. I don't know what she's going to be doing. She wants to look at her form.
I don't use gyms for my form. I just mirrors,
I'm should say I never use those for my form.
I wait until after I'm done lifting. And then I used a mirror to flexing.
I just walk off and go, yeah, right. That's all I use it for.
That's why there's always debt's going to be a lot of breadth marks on my, uh,
my fucking mirror. Um, I can't fucking wait.
And, um, so my goal is every day before work,
this thing I'm working on that I'm not allowed to talk about, um,
is I'm going to work out in the morning, take my dog for a hike,
I'm going to work out in the morning,
and then I'm going to put it in a solid fucking day. And at the end of the day,
I'm going to come home.
Daddy's going to have a little bingo bangle and I'm going to talk to my lovely
wife and I'm going to go to bed. That's what my life's going to be like. Um,
that is the goal. Anyways, you know.
So this contractor that I have working on this thing, yeah.
Unlike my last one is a fucking guys writer's rank.
So, uh, it's been, it's been a fucking wonderful thing. However,
let's stop talking about this bullshit. All right.
Um, how about the fucking NHL playoffs? Playoffs. Oh, first of all,
congratulations to the Golden State Warriors.
73 fucking wins. 73 and nine.
I gotta tell you, I don't know. That took 20 years for someone to beat 72.
Do you think somebody ever beats? I mean,
think it's a single digit loss for the season.
That's fucking unbelievable. That's, that's about as borderline on, bro.
I think that that really, um, well, you know,
I don't know enough about who po, who had, who had the record before the bulls.
Like how long those records last? I'm 73 and nine.
That's, that's going to be a tough one. It's basically the,
not even the 96 bulls won that many fucking games. Um,
but I, you know, those guys, if you had that carrot dangling in front of them,
they'd somehow fucking figure out how to win 70.
Somebody's got to go 74 and eight. I don't know that you can do that. Um,
and I don't know that I know all the rules of basketball either.
So take that with a giant grain of salt.
Um,
congratulations to them and congratulations to Koby Bryant Hall of fame career
going out with 60 points on 50 shots, which I thought was perfect.
You never considered your teammates your entire career.
Why would you do it on your last night?
Okay.
I thought it was the perfect way. Went out and I love that Nike Commercial,
the Nike commercial where he stands in the middle of the court and the Celtic
fans, really an actor in Celtic gear gets up and starts singing to him.
I just add all the fans around the league are singing how they hate them,
but they really love him and respect him. And there's no other teammates. No.
Are the Lakers?
No fucking nod to the past of fucking magic and Kareem,
no thanks Phil Jackson. No nothing.
Just Coby standing in the middle of the court in the fucking Christ pose with
his fucking arms out and it was absolutely fucking perfect. Great job.
Nike. Great fucking job.
Um,
one of the greatest one-on-one fucking players you're ever gonna see,
one of the greatest outside shooters you're ever going to see. And uh,
one of the biggest cancer's in a locker room that ever fucking existed more.
He was sort of the second coming of will Chamberland as far as the,
the points that he scored versus what the fuck he did in the locker room. And
um,
I just thought it was fucking pervy took 50 fucking shots.
Ah,
I don't, I don't think it could have been any more perfect. That was just,
it was phenomenal. And it was, that is Coby. He takes 50 shots. He annoys you,
but he scored 60 points. You know what I mean?
I honestly think that I could have played on a lot of those Laker tease because
he, you know, he's not going to throw it to you anyways.
I could have run up and down the court, my fucking pasty legs.
How bad would my pasty thighs look in those fucking golden uniforms?
Ugh.
Unbelievable.
Or even worse than when they had those white ones there for a while.
The home white ones. It just be like, I don't know,
you'd have that little bit of fringe to kind of break at the end of it to break
up the shorts and my fucking milk thighs and then maybe I had some socks.
I don't fuck, I don't know. Jesus. They're even,
that vision is fucking disturbing to me. Um, anyways. Uh,
let me do a little bit of a little bit of advertising here as I'm checking in on
you and this lovely fucking day.
I'm taping the fucking flyers and capitals right now.
Um,
what do we got here? Oh, Jesus club Dhabi. Everybody Club, Gabby Club.
Debbie at daddy loves GM club. Debbie, if you're anything like me,
then you knew exactly what you like and how you like it except when you're in
the wine aisle. Tannins into Rorys.
I don't know how to say any of these means.
Nothing to you unless you happen to be a fancy pants professional.
Some of the um, please include all the falling points. Absolutely. Alright,
well with club Gabby plugged, Debbie, you all been to west bend, you or,
um, the guessing game is over.
Club w I got all my big boy pants is the world's only personalized wine club.
And your wines are sent directly to your door. Uh,
not only does club w you don't care if taco bell send you wine.
They send you wine that you'll love drinking.
That's because club Debbie tear looking for some weapons of mass destruction.
Easy to use.
Six question quiz figures out your pallet so that every bottle you receive is
perfectly tailored to your tastes club. Debbie used to be an alcoholic.
Now I speak Spanish is leading the great to glass wine revolution.
They worked directly with the vignettes to cut out the middleman,
which saves you some Dinero Club. Debbie,
I'm running out of references and go down to get more, uh,
even offers a no risk guarantee that you'll love what they'll send you or your
money back. Call to action right now. It Club W my dad was a war hero,
is offering my listeners 50% off your first order when you go to club w.
Dot com slash burr why? It should be fun. Not Pretentious. Well,
you don't need to dumb it down either. I think you should have, you know,
in wine. Isn't that difficult? Is it? It's a little intimidating.
Start learning as you drink it.
Club debby.com/burr you even get 50% off your first order.
That's club w.com/burr. All right, two more.
Everybody tracker or as I say, trap
SMAD cast SMAD phone, smart homes.
Technology has made everything Matt.
But losing your stuff stills still make smart people feel really stupid too.
He's fucking wicked stupid track makes losing things.
A thing of the past tracker is a coin size device that locates misplaced keys,
wallets, bags, computers,
anything in seconds just paired to your smartphone,
attach it to anything and it finds its precise location with the tap of a
button. It's that easy. Lose your phone,
press the button on track and your phone rings even when it's on silent.
How fucking creepy is that with over 1.5 million devices tracker has the largest
crowd gps network in the world. World. World, world. Yeah, yeah,
yeah. So your lost items show up on the map. Even if it's miles away,
never lose anything again with fucking tracking.
Listen to this show.
Get a special discount offer of 40% off your first tracker device.
Go to tracker.com and enter the Promo code birth.
The hardest thing you'll ever have to fight again.
Go to tracker.com right now and enter the Promo code birth for 40% off. Again,
that's tracker.com Promo Code Burr. All right,
Hellickson Helix. Is it the band? What is it? Uh,
what is it about buying a mattress that makes you feel in all skeevy and
violated? Is it the pushy salespeople?
Is it the homeless guy who just walked in off the street and rolled his head
around the pillows, the fake President Day sale or the fact that you know,
you'll regret what you bought as you do the walk of shame out of the mattress
store? Well, what happened in there? Huh? Uh, those days are over.
Thanks to Hellickson or helix sleep where you can buy a mattress online,
customized for you for hundreds of dollars instead of thousands. Well,
how do you test it out? Go to helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions I hear it is,
this is how you test it out by answering a few simple questions and helix
creates your custom sleep profile to build you the perfect mattress.
The results. Our customers report a 30% improvement in overall sleep.
I'd love to read this questionnaire.
Do you pleasure yourself at what time of the day do you feel like you want to
feel like there's a foot in your back? As you're rubbing one out, uh,
your mattress will arrive at your door in about a week and shipping is 100% free
, uh, free. You have a hundred a hundred nights to try it out.
And if you don't love it, they'll pick it up for free and give you 100% refund.
Good Lord. What the fuck did they do with that mattress? No questions asked.
It's like it never happened. Oh my God. And it goes, where does it go?
Go somewhere to the South Pacific. If you do love your new helix smack mattress,
keep it in and your dignity. That's why everyone in GQ magazine,
what they do with the mattress,
they ship it back and whoever made the thing in the sweatshop gets executed and
then they fall out of the mattress and they fold them up and throw them in the
ocean. That's what's really going on behind the scenes.
If you do love your new helix mattress, keep it and your you and your dignity.
That's why everyone from GQ magazines to Forbes are all talking about helicopter
helix, sleep. Oh, it's not because you're paying them to,
that's why I'm talking about go to
helix.com/burn and get $50 off your order. That's helix sleep.com/bar he leaks
sleep.com/bar all right, that's it for that bullshit. Um,
what am I going to left here? 23 more fucking minutes. Oh,
I was driving home today. Bududa aloo dude.
And somebody in front of me was smoking a cigar and I had my phone, my Ed,
my window down just a little bit. This is how much this habit has me.
I was like, oh my God. And I rolled it all the way down and was like, yeah,
go ahead, dog sticks a 10 out the window or ace Ventura.
That's what I was doing,
driving behind the guy and I was trying to figure it and I drove up next to him
going like, wow, the fucking guy's smoking his cigar in that nice car.
That's some old school shit. And they pulled up and it wasn't him and um,
I couldn't, you know,
I couldn't figure out who was smoking the cigar and I realized that cigar smoke
is so fucking stinky.
It could've literally just been like three people smoking on a porch and I drove
by and God damn and I'm missing. Okay.
I Dunno if this is a good idea, you guys,
this whole fucking two cigars a month because this is like when I try to go easy
with the booze and you know, when I go,
when I try to take long periods of time off from boozing, it doesn't make me go,
you know what? I don't think, I don't think I miss drinking.
I don't ever need to drink again. What it makes me feel like is, you know,
I would like to drink a case of beer by myself and see if I can finish a fifth
object annually. That's what it makes me feel like.
So I think I need to feed the beast a little bit. Um,
having said that til I drove her home behind the person smoking that
unbelievably wonderful smelling cigar, I um,
I was actually going like, you know what? I think I can make it to my birthday,
which is in June. And if I didn't do that, then I would be,
how many did I smoke this year to? Four, six and a half.
Six and a half. Because one when I smoked half and it wasn't smoking. Well,
sweet. I still count that one. So six and a half.
That would be June and I would be looking at like, I'd smoked about one a month.
Right. I think that'd be all right. I think that would be okay.
You know, actually, in reality, could she just do heroin once a month?
If you just did heroin once a month, 12 times a fucking year,
if you didn't do it 12 days in a row, six days in a row. So it didn't get you,
you just did it. That's what they ought to have.
They ought to just have like the heroin spot,
right? And you got a fucking punch card. There's no way to falsify it.
No way to sell somebody else's or whatever.
And just once a month like would you try it just to see what it was like if
there was just fucking heroin, you could go,
you could fucking try it and no matter how bad and if you just like,
I just wanted to do it once just to see what it felt like.
And then you just walk away and you never do it again.
Or if like you kind of, you liked it, right?
Which why wouldn't you? I heard it's like the greatest feeling ever. Right?
Why if they, if they fucking managed it for you
and you just had that fucking bitch and there was just nothing you could do
about it. And then once a month you go in, you shoot up,
it's fucking awesome and everybody can be excited
like coming up, you know? And they have like a, like a,
every the beginning of every month they'd have like a Raffle, right? Like,
like um, what do you call it?
The lottery and instead of like nine balls coming out, it's just one ball,
right? It just comes out right? It comes out all right.
Month. April,
heroine day is the 17th seventh Emmy's a god fuck 17 [inaudible] the everybody
does smack on the 17th except for people that you know,
got to keep like reactors going and shit like that.
They get to do it on like the 18th provided this someone then someone to be hung
over from heroin or whatever the, fuck you kidding. I don't know.
We'd have to work that out. Catch just have heroin day,
you know,
once a week everybody just gets fucked up and you can opt out right once a month
to do heroin and then you have like, you know,
Bose and days, there's gotta be a way to do it
where the government just becomes a big fucking drug dealer and babysitter now.
But the, he imagine the fucking lines in. If everybody's got to get ahead,
that doesn't work. I guess you got to manage it yourself.
I guess that is the problem. You know the government won't step in then.
You know what?
They can't collect enough money off of these super rich fucking people.
That's what it is.
They get the money outside the country and then you got too many other people
sitting around their sweatpants and they don't want to fucking work, you know,
and then fucking, you know, regular people,
regular people like us right down the fucking metal.
I'm going to say everybody listen to this podcast is regular.
He's somewhere somewhere right in the middle. Huh?
Pay In taxes out the fucking ass, aren't ya? Ah.
Shouldn't you get heroin once a month, once a month.
The heroin store. That's where they should do for the middle class.
That's getting squeezed out. You just once a month,
they shoot you up once every couple of months you get to this side,
but no more than once a month.
You know you do it on a Saturday, right? You're just fucking not enough.
And that's it. One Nice fucking dose and then,
I dunno what you shiver and shake a little bit. Eat some fucking Jett, one dose.
You're not going to get hooked at you. You know, and I gotta look this up.
Heroin once a month. Hey,
little girl, do some heroin once a fucking month.
I don't think you'll get addicted.
I always spelled this wrong, by the way. No Ian, it no heroes here.
Heroin once a month.
All right.
Heroin Rehab, treatment opinions. Can the use of heroin be casual?
This is the beginning of a life changing decision right here.
Can you use heroin? Okay. Know, and all of us too. It's a chat room.
Okay. It seems from all government propaganda, don't we love it?
And most threads in discussions here on whatever this is,
that heroin is for addicts and junkies.
Is it the case that one can take heroin for a onetime experiment slash
experience in order to witness the effects? Uh, please share.
Um, that's not a good word to use in a heroin chat. Roma, uh,
please share experiences with each, with one time users versus long time.
All right. Yes.
There are people who will use heroin once or a few times and will not return to
it. Usually it takes two or more tries to really enjoy it.
First time users usually feel a bit nauseous or used to back in the day this was
smoking. This means you will not be a fuck you. Fuck you.
You're just some regular person. I want a doctor, uh,
answers. Let's go to answers.yahoo.com.
Come on.
Come on. Low. Debbie, go. Is it, can you use heroin one time? Ah,
best answer. Capital. No, not at all.
I'm a retired heroin dealer.
I know what happened to my customers when they tried to only use it casually
when they were partying. They became addicted. Their lives became miserable.
A lot of them ended up homeless in jail, losing jobs,
flunking out of college while I profited off them.
Let's see if that comes in here and any other bad luck you can think of.
Their families ended up being prostitutes.
Heroin use is completely miserable life and there's no way to use it
responsibly.
People can become addicted to heroin the first time they use it and try it,
Yada, Yada, Yada. This other person said, it's very, very unlikely.
I'm a foreign heroin addict who's in a Methadone program right now and you're in
a chat room. Fucking multitasking.
Another person that may be possible for some personalities.
Is it worth the risk? What is the benefit to gain? Somebody says,
don't know. Go roll up a fatty.
What was that movie where Alan Arkin just started using heroin when he was like
80 if I were to shoot heroin once a week for the rest of my life.
Let's see here. This is on reddit. This is the last one.
Hypothetical, of course, never done it. A Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I'm interested in the effects.
Suppose I shut up a purely and safe safely measured dose every Friday.
Where would you get that from a drug dealer. I mean it's not regulated.
All right. You know what,
this is probably one of the dumbest questions I've ever asked in mercifully the
half hour is over. Um, so don't do it people.
Okay.
I, you know, it's something I've never heard the expression recreational heroin,
heroin user,
although God knows somebody is going to write in and claim that they could do
it. So you know what more power to you, but I would never fuck with that. Um,
anyways, this has been the Thursday afternoon, just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast. Just checking in idea. Um,
please enjoy the music and uh, and then I dunno,
we got some classic kits from Monday morning podcast gone by.
Have a great weekend. You Con uh,
congratulations to the penguins went in there first one,
congratulations to the St Louis.
May Be in St Louis.
Louis make may at the fair number. That one.
Don't tell me the lights are shine in every place.
There we are all day.
She cook cheese. I'm like,
that you will be my something or do g and meet me in St Louis.
Louie meet me at the fair. That's what you did back in the day.
You met some woman saying, Hey,
you know I love your dress down to your ankles and your giant hat.
Why don't you meet me in St Louis Louis and uh, meet me at the fair.
And then she'd be like, why on earth are you going to do that? And you're like,
cause we're gonna fuck. 'Em All right, that's the podcast.
Have a great weekend. Your cuts and I'll talk to you on Monday.
Yo
[inaudible] [inaudible]
the show phony. Whose been
[inaudible] that's before I left,
before I go to the, into the trees. I hit my hay.
Hey, what's going on? It's bill bar.
It's the Monday morning morning podcast and I'm doing it on Tuesday because,
uh, cause you know what,
I did one yesterday and I was in the,
I was in an airport again and uh, it just suck. That's what happened.
It started off good. You know what I mean?
And then it was like evil Knievel when he was jumping the snake river, you know,
and they fucking, uh, they let them off. You know, when he went across,
you're like, Holy Shit, he's going to make, he's go to pass.
You came out and he just fucking went straight down. So that's what happened.
He went right into the fucking river and somehow all they got was a bloody nose.
Um, that's what happened to me yesterday. I went to do the podcast, um,
as I was waiting to get on my jet blue flight, exit row was all set,
everything was great. And uh, you know,
all of a sudden they said that we were switching planes.
We had to get off the fucking plane. That's what happened.
Then I was in the terminal and then I was pissing in the airport again.
And how many have I done that on my podcast? Oh, I'm bill burrow.
I'm in an airport. I'm not happy. You know what I mean?
Did he really want to fucking hear that story again? And uh,
so I was getting self conscious about that. That's what happened.
Now that that's the real thing. That's what happened.
Then I got self conscious about it,
which made me lose my train of thought and the whole thing lost its fucking
momentum.
And the whole podcast went right down to the snake river and that's what
happened. Okay.
And my nose is bleeding on the plane and everybody thought I was doing coke and
I was trying to say that I wasn't. And then the stewardess was just like,
is there a problem sir? Is there a problem? You know,
she waved the Patriot Act to my face. Um, all right.
So anyways, uh, this spill burrows, I mentioned at the top of the poor coast,
um, if you're new to my page, I do one of these every single Monday. All right.
And I have to think that somebody new to my page because a,
I had my big fancy special, uh, Sunday night.
Why do I do this on comedy central? And if I had half a brain,
I could give you some times as to when it's going to be replaying again,
which of course I don't know. But, um,
I watched three seconds of it cause I can't stand looking at myself and I
thought it looked fucking awesome and, uh, I was happy with it and I want to,
before I get into my bitch and for the week and all that shit,
which I really can't because I'm a really happy about my special,
so there won't be a lot of bitching. I shouldn't have said that. Cause I,
you know, by the end of this thing, we'll be fucking bitching about something.
But, um, I just want to thank everybody who, uh,
sent me emails telling me how much they liked it. Um, uh,
that really means a lot to me. And I gotta tell you something, man. Yeah.
I don't know about other comics, but I freak right before those things come out.
You know what I mean? I sit there thinking like, oh my God,
what if everybody thinks it sucks? And I'm like, no, don't do it. It's good.
It's good. Right. You liked it, you saw it. And I know, but what are,
what if for the people who fucking, I stopped playing that mental tennis,
you know, I'm standing in a Blimpie or a subway,
trying to think what kind of bread I want to get when it's really all the same
kind of fucking bread. Like how they got that little fucking little oven.
They're like, they're like, it's the old country, like you're in Europe. Oh Wow.
And they're baking bread there. I say, ah, it's just such a fucking scam.
Look at me. I'm already pitching now. Let's keep it happy. Keep it happy.
So yeah, so basically, yeah, it was kind of freaking, you know,
you want people to like what you do. And uh,
if I liked who I was as a person and I was comfortable with myself,
I would have no need to get on a stage and act like a jackass for fucking hour
for other people's approval that I've never even met. Okay. So they go, so this,
so anybody who was going to ask me that question like, dude,
you'd love sweet guy right before you had like a special coming out, like,
you know what I mean? Like totally rolling on the floor, laughing my ass off.
Ah, yes. Yes I do. I do like totally fucking freak out.
Um, all right. Okay. So before I get going here with the podcast,
which is a day late and hopefully not a dollar short,
I apologize to all my regular listeners, all 14 of you.
Um, you know what sucks.
I got a bunch of friend requests and I thought I was finally going to be able to
get up past fucking 28,000 and I added everybody.
I was 28,992 I wanted to get to 29,000.
God dammit.
I swear to God there's a fucking conspiracy here and you know what it is?
It's the fucking Rothschild family and they're all over Facebook.
And I'm telling you that's the scam. That's the new scam.
And it's time few people to fucking wake up and realize that your social
networking, Internet rights and freedoms are being taken away from you.
I'm Joe Biden. You know, I don't even know who Joe Biden is.
I've just been hearing his name in the background, kind of like,
he's like the Jonas brothers in my cultural worlds.
Like every time I walk by a magazine,
it's either his face or the Jonas brothers and I don't know either one of their
material that the Jonas brothers started started singing a speech of Joe Biden
and you told me that that was a number one hit and teenage girls loved it.
I'd have to agree with you.
Those Jonas brothers really wear tight clothes, don't they?
Is that where the hair is? So curly? Thank you. Right?
There's one full year as little monologue joke for you. They really do.
They just look really chunky.
Like they're going to be fat fucks when they get older. You know what I mean?
Which would be hilarious. Not like they're going to be obese,
but they're going to have that fat middle aged face.
And that's the big thing that nobody talks about when you get middle aged like
me, is trying not to have a fat porky fig pig face.
It's the weirdest thing. Even if you're in shape,
you still get that fucking swollen Ed. The cheeks,
you get the Winston Churchill face, you know
jolly, you get the jelly rosy cheeks. You know what it is? It's the booze man.
It's the fucking booze, which I have laid off for uh,
about two and a half weeks,
I've had a beer and a half at a half a beer at a,
uh, the uninformed taping that I did with Joe de Rosa, my XM radio show.
I had half a beer at that. And let me tell you something.
You stopped drinking beer for two weeks and you drink, you take a sip of a beer.
It's one of the greatest things you've ever tasted in your life. It's delicious.
Like you ever once Shashank redemption and a Tim Robbins when he sitting on the
roof and he gives that,
that Conti fucking gorilla maniac guard tax advice.
And all he wants is some suds as he talks about.
He talks about just the way he described sitting on that roof.
I guess it's Morgan Freeman's character describes drinking that beer that always
makes me want to drink a fucking beer. You know,
just drink at 12 like there was a fucking flight in my apartment that he doesn't
realize it, but his life is ending today. You know what I mean?
I being like that, you know,
I know it's just a fucking insect and shit and you know,
you kill this and then all of a sudden the bees start dropping off. But he's,
he's fucking obnoxious.
You don't even have a house fly in and spending your house for a couple of days.
You know, he started, you know, it's,
he's kind of like an athlete and the toilet twilight of his career.
It's like Brett Farve and the jets, you know,
it's exactly that mother fucker sitting right there. Let's try to kill,
this is the first time I've tried to kill sly Brent on my podcast and see on the
inside, this is the big thing in the middle. Is it on the inside or the outside?
All right. One, two, three
mother fucker. I got you. Bam. Right between the blinds. There you go.
So someday when the insects take over this podcast,
this podcast, this is what's going to take me down. Then I'll try to be like,
no, that wasn't me. That was somebody else. I sold my act to my brother,
just like that Guy Gallagher. I sold the podcast to him. Bill Burr,
part two when he was doing it all. That was fucking satisfying. Alright,
you, it'd be hilarious if somebody actually sent me a complaint.
Could somebody send me an email complaining about the fact that I just murdered
an insect mocking those fucking Peta maniacs.
You know what I'm saying? And I love animals too, but I just hate groups.
I hate groups of people because in order to get noticed,
they just make a lot of noise and they never come up with a good chance.
And it's just, I don't know, it's just fucking annoying to knowing.
And they gotta do they gotta try to be shocking, you know, like, you know,
it really sucks. And there's those commercials that they make about cigarettes.
Have you seen that? They always do some public demonstration.
I didn't know what the fuck the name of those commercials are,
but this so fucking annoying that he, they just uh,
they make me want to smoke.
Just I wouldn't smoke, but you know what I mean, like I can't even explain it.
And so it's like, you know,
they make me want to do something that I don't even want to fucking do.
All right. Whatever. You guys get the point. All right. Whatever.
It's really just me. Just send me a text message.
Joe Brought Nick comedian out of, uh, San Francisco via fucking, uh,
Pittsburgh said, uh,
we went to the UCLA Bruin game last night.
That's another reason why I didn't do the podcast cause I got off the plane,
I got off the plane over there man and a cheat.
You get the Yale and I uh,
went right over to the rose bowl and I went to the UCLA, Tennessee,
Tennessee game. Fucking unbelievable game.
Went into overtime and a UCLA won it.
And I think I have a team out here. I was,
I got so fucking into that cam tie something. If you guys,
if you're into pro sports, take a second. Look at college football.
I know everybody's psyched about the NFL dude. It's fucking bananas.
It's unbelievable.
And I just think bananas want to [inaudible] I just really hate myself sometimes
it's spoken bananas. It's wacky.
Said Bananas. You know,
I just made myself sound like I go to games with one of those raccoon coats from
the 1920s Rob Rah. Just boom by. Um, but no, it's insane. You know,
you got like the bands going crazy. The students are going crazy.
They got all those chants and stuff. It's the closest thing America has to like,
you have a like watch those, those,
some of the soccer or football as they call it over in England where people are
just going bananas. Uh, I said bananas again. Jay's is quite,
if I say it one more time, I'm going to have to hang up on myself.
When the fuck did I start saying bananas?
You know what that's on my friends and everyone around me in my life,
but not say it. Dude, why the fuck do you say that?
You really need to stop saying that.
It's like some of my relatives in Boston who say, Pissa you see that game dude?
Yeah, dude, it was Pissa you're like fucking in there. 40 still saying that.
It's just, it makes my fucking skin crawl, but then I'm saying bananas.
All right. But anyways, I'm in college football. I'm actually,
I'm doing a gig coming up in Austin,
Texas and I'm going to a Texas longhorn Missouri game. I'm going to be there.
So if you're one of the hundred thousand fucking maniacs,
who was there going nuts rather than bananas?
What's a good way to say bananas is my podcast question for you.
All right. And speaking of podcast questions, there's a segue for you.
Um, we're going to get into the podcast questions, but first,
a moment from our sponsor. Last week I talked about, uh, state capitals.
Um, did you miss that episode? Well,
maybe she listened to that half hour of babbling and, uh,
I was Kinda asking the question is why the fuck is it always the,
the second rate city always seems to be the capital, you know what I mean?
Like it's never a, you know, New York, it's not in New York City.
That's what you'd think it would be. But it's Albany. Okay. It's,
you go to Illinois, it's not Chicago with Springfield. You go to Pennsylvania,
it's not Philly, Pittsburgh, it's Harrisburg. It's always something like,
what the fuck? You know? And I thought it was,
cause people initially thought that that was the town that was going to be the
shit. And uh,
then it stopped being the shit and another time became the shit that they
already made it be the capital and they were too embarrassed to say that they
made a mistake. You know what I mean?
It's kind of like the people like the Jonas brothers right now, you know,
the Jonas brothers are the, uh, musical equivalent to the city of Albany.
That's what I'm trying, that's what I'm trying to say there. Um,
so anyways, this guy tries to claim,
he says on the topic of why cities like Harrisburg and almond is Albany,
are state capitols over Philly or New York City.
The reason is because most state capitols are located geographically in the
center of the state.
That way local government government officials wouldn't have to travel across
the whole state to get to the capitol.
There are a few exceptions like Carson city and Tallahassee,
but overall that's the general reason why shit cities are capitals.
Is that true? Wait a minute. Boston that's not in the middle of the state
is providence. Providence kind of is. I Dunno. Is that true?
I actually got in an argument the guy the other day, Pete Dominick comedian,
and he goes, cite your sources. You need three sources, just like journalism.
And I realized that not only do I not have three sources,
I usually don't even have one.
I just have my gut going and it sounds like fucking bullshit.
And then I just spin it. So I sound like I know what I'm talking about.
So can anybody back up with that guy saying, is that the real reason for that?
Huh? Anybody? Um, all right. That's it.
Let's get into the questions for this week. The podcast questions.
Question number one. Hey Bill, I have a question for your podcast. Um,
if you are locked in, this is a great question. By the way.
This is one of the greatest questions I've, I've ever gotten. Okay.
This guy is setting the fucking bar for podcast questions.
All right, here's the questions. Here's the question. Sorry.
If you were locked in a gymnasium full of hundreds of unarmed six-year-olds of
various weights, heights, races, and temperaments,
and all you had were the clothes on your back,
how many of them do you think you could kill before they overpowered you?
What a fucking great question. All right,
so obviously I'm setting all morals aside here.
If you set aside all morals and all feelings of guilt and,
uh, well, maybe I just felt like I was right, like these were evil kids.
I'm trying to think of a reason why a gymnasium full of six-year-olds of various
weights, Tyson races and temperaments,
how many do I think I could fucking kill before they overpowered me? Uh,
let's see here. The average a six year old has gotta be about,
are they four feet men at four feet tall?
Like fucking Tim Duncan was probably four feet tall when he was six there.
Any future NBA players in this? If they're not,
if it just going to be like accountants and fucking, you know,
occasional wifebeater, that'd be the tough one.
I think you know what I'd have to do, do they know I'm going to overpower me?
I'm just going to have to assume like if they know that I'm coming in there as
the killer of six year olds, so they all banded together to try to slay me.
I mean I think the first thing I'd have to do,
not just not to hack off of ESPN analysts here and use one of their expressions,
but I'm going to have to here.
I think the first thing I'd have to do is I'd have to set the tone and a,
by setting the tone,
I mean I just have to do something so fucked up to the first wave of Braveheart,
six-year-olds coming at me that I would have that gift, those steps. Second way,
that split second of thinking about what the fuck they were doing. Right.
And, uh, I'm talking about leg sweeps,
the kind that would, that would blow out in adult ACL. Okay. Which I'm talking,
yeah, I'm wearing timberlands and uh, I'm gonna fucking,
I get one of them with one of those, you know, you remember that move.
What's his face used to do?
Andre the giant when they throw a dude off the ropes and he just stick his foot
up.
I don't know, man. I don't know how, fuck, I don't know how many I could get,
how many I could kill.
I'd have to fuck him up first and leave 'em dazed and then I'd have to go back
to finishing them off. But, uh, if I just had to use my fist man, you know,
even though there's six year old that's still a skull, it's going to hurt. Wow.
I'm getting really creepy with this. Aren't okay.
I would say I could probably fuck up.
I could kill about 11 I could kill 11. But you know, I, you know what,
you know, I think that I could kill the number that low is because Emma,
one time on the discovery channel, I saw this wasp entered this,
this beehive of these honeybees,
and like the wasps or whatever the fuck it was can destroy the honeybees.
They can kill like a hundred to one. They can destroy these fuckers.
So what happened was he went in there, he was doing surveillance for his,
his wasp or his horn and nest.
And then now he's going to go back and get his boys and they were all gonna come
back or he's sending on a signal for them to come.
So what he didn't realize was the honeybees som and they started like whittling
their asses as a signal. And what happened was,
is that the exact fucking moment,
all the honeybees jumped on the fucking wasp or the horn at the same time.
And they want tops of them and they started like basically dry humping them.
But what they really would do when they will vibrating,
and I guess a Hornet can only survive in temperatures up to 116 degrees,
where a honeybee can go up to 118 degrees. So these mother fuckers,
they vibrated to the point where the temperature was 118 degrees,
one degree fucking more away, 117 degrees,
one degree more than the Horner could, could fucking survive.
And one degree less than what would fucking kill them. It was,
it was one of the greatest attacks. MERCI. Emulate.
And they basically cook the fucker. And that was the end of him.
So get those six year olds knew I was coming and they all jumped on me and
started fucking vibrating being a redhead. I mean once they got over 80 degrees,
I would be fucked. I'd be passed out. And that would be the end of it all.
They'd have to do is drag my unconscious carcass out into the sun and then that
would be it. That would be at deaths by third degree. Sunburns.
All right, Jesus. I'm like got a Brett from answering that one. Okay.
When am I getting onto overrated? Underrated. Then I've got to get on with my,
uh, with my day here as to you. Who's kidding? Who,
why am I acting like I'm the only busy one? All right.
For those of you new to my podcast, last couple of weeks,
people have been sending me in a their list of stuff that they think is
overrated and underrated. I'll say as a new UCLA Bruin Fan,
you know what I find fucking overrated. The fucking Tennessee volunteers.
What do you think about that? Ranked 18th against UCLA where they ranked 44th,
the third string quarterback. What a checklist. Height game.
The guy two for pickups, one for a touchdown the first half,
and then he came out in the second half. Like fucking Joe Montana, Kurt Warner,
and maybe even Fran Tarkington. Um, all right.
You know what actually is overrated is underrated, is a man's ability to shower,
shave, and be ready and in the fucking car within 15 minutes.
I experienced that this weekend when Finney brand,
the beloved owner of the Stress Factory in New Jersey took me out on his boat.
Okay. And we came back,
the show was in an hour and there was some sort of boat house and he's like,
he talks like fucking, you know, a muppet. He's like, oh, I gotta go on there.
I go, no, I got to take a shower. Just sign on a second.
He leaves me in the car with his awful fucking Bruce Springsteen CD cause
everybody in New Jersey loves Bruce Springsteen. So, uh,
he goes in and I'm thinking it's going to be, fuck,
he's going to be in it for 25 fucking minutes. This dude in and out came out,
you know, he looked great, smelled of man soap and he was fucking ready to go.
He actually make, made me feel unclean within 10 minutes.
It's an incredible thing. So that's my overrated, underrated for the week. Okay,
here's everybody else's. Alright. Overrated. Stella Beer.
It tastes just like Budweiser and every non tasting having schlepped insists
it's a quality beer. I guess nobody's heard of Lam.
Lango needas or Doug fish head. You know what?
I've never heard of those either and I can't pass judgment on those,
but those sounds like those kinds of beers that I see when I go to Colorado and
there's those, those rafting, hippy, I'm into Dave Matthews,
Bergen stock, hacky sack fuckers drinking, that kind of shit.
You know when you go down there and they have those,
those fucking microbrews I think microbrews overrated,
but the best one I did, I went to, it was the one I told you down on Nantucket.
Cisco Breweries, man, God damn. And I'm still waiting for my vodka by the way.
You sons of bitches. I understand your mom and pop, but what the fuck?
I got three bottles of AAA coming my way and I've since quit drinking.
Maybe they listened to the podcast. All right,
overrated hyped up bachelor parties. Oh, isn't that the truth?
You always think it's going to be like a fucking movie. This guy says,
if you have to wear a tee shirt that says something like stick a fork in them,
it's almost guaranteed that it's going to be a queer fest.
Especially. There's definitely going to be at least one dip. Shit.
That is way too into taking pictures.
I know how gay is that guys can't take pictures. That's fucking gay.
One day some gay about me, I'm actually in the flowers to a like, it's so gay.
It goes beyond gay and comes back into a heterosexual,
I think. No it doesn't. Maybe it comes to a sort of gay,
heterosexual, I dunno. I like flowers. I realized that about myself.
I bought a couple of basses and every week I'd come off the road.
I was actually arranging them today,
like measuring the stems and looking at the colors to try set them up.
I've got like these days, right? I got one.
His yellow ones like this sort of like a,
you ever see a fender strat when they got that sunburst finish?
That's what it looks like. Then I got like these three lavender.
Once I put the lavender ones in the back, they'd like the backup singers.
You know what I mean? You know like those,
those big black chicks they always have behind the skinny white girl who can't
fucking sing. You know? That's how I arrange them.
I put the pair ones up front. That's like Paul Simon. That's what it is.
It's like Paul Simon on the rhythm of the saints tour.
That's how I arrange them. And A, I don't know. I look at them,
they make me feel good and you know,
I'm comfortable enough with myself to be able to admit that. All right.
Another overrated thing. Somebody said Notre Dame and he said,
I can go on forever forever about this one,
but the amount of ass that a blue chip or gives up not playing in places like
South Beach, Miami or southern California because he just had to wear,
because he just had to wear the gold helmet sickens me. Oh, isn't that true?
That's the true, yeah, but if you play for the University of Miami, man,
that's a fucking dangerous place. That's a God damn dangerous place, man.
You guys have fatalities on the regular, on your team?
And I just say on the regular, what did I rent fucking Friday last night?
How do I start off saying bananas and then I go with on the, on the regular, um,
you know, stuff that I always wanted to go to university of Miami game,
but I wanted to go when they played in the orange bowl.
Now they playing the Joe Robbie, it just doesn't seem right.
You know what I mean? Um, okay. Another thing,
overrated Asian Pussy. I'm not sure what I was expecting,
but I'll be honest. I was expecting more. Uh,
well did you ever think that maybe the Asian you hooked up with wasn't good in
bed? I mean, you're going to judge an entire continent. You know,
it's funny is when people say Asian immediately, myself included,
it doesn't everybody think, you know, Chinese, Japanese, Korean, Vietnamese,
anybody, you know, with the, uh, quote unquote, uh, Asian eyes,
whatever the politically correct way of saying what the fucking Spanish
basketball team was trying to do. But that also could be mean.
You looked up from somebody from India and they, they stunk in bed.
You know what I mean? I think you should, uh, listen, there's fucking hotties
let you know what this, this deserves a follow up question.
How many Asians did you hook up with before you decided to do an entire
continent of pussy? I mean, that, that's pretty amazing.
That's one of the biggest continents out there. If not the biggest is it?
I had no fucking, it was Africa. Bigger Africa is bigger,
but I gotta tell you something. Asia's on the rise too. So, you know,
be watch what you say. Okay. You saw what China did in the Olympics.
They can do that on the rings. Just think what they can do in the a fucking,
I dunno. Computer industry. All right, let's get to, uh,
let's get the underrated, underrated.
This guy says that early nineties gangster rap videos,
hands down the greatest videos ever made.
Just a bunch of black dudes hanging out in Compton with their baseball caps.
Blurt out. I miss those days. Uh, I gotta agree with you, man.
Those were fucking great days.
Remember that time they was at really pretty girl at the party and they all
shake up their forties and they'd dump it on her head because she, you know,
she thought she was the shit. You know what the reality is,
is they were looking at her thinking that she thought that she was the shit for
all, you know, she was fucking, she was probably insecure.
Like a lot of beautiful women are, you know, he's got some sorta hang up.
Oh my God, I hate my ankles. You know some,
she was probably thinking that cause she wasn't wearing jeans.
She's wearing that little Horry outfit. So she's actually getting her head,
which caused her to have a shutdown look on her face.
So then snoop it or whoever,
Dre or Warren g or whoever the fuck it was out there and Kelly, they all,
oh look at this bitch sheet. She's all fucking stuck up.
And then they shook up their forties and they dumped it over fucking head.
And she probably ran home crying thinking that they did it because they didn't
like our ankles. And you know what, that probably led to her being a stripper.
That's how it happens. All right. Uh, underrated. Ricky Gervais'.
Sky's made two great TV shows in less than five years,
less than five years of each other.
And he still doesn't get the Kudos he deserves.
Maybe it's because there's no laugh track. Who knows? I gotta say something.
Ricky Gervais' is a fucking genius.
And if you never saw the original version of the office,
no offense to the American version, it's unbelievable. He, that guy,
that guy is a genius. That one, I can't remember what the episode was about,
but that one where he plays the guitar in the middle of the meeting is the most
uncomfortable, hilarious fucking thing I've ever seen. And that guy,
I like how he has a drinking problem and how being an alcoholic is still funny
in England. You can make fun of people having drinking problems over here.
It's other, we got to have an intervention. Well, you doing this to yourself.
I'm all right. We're winding down here. Ah, the movie base, Get Ball,
David Zucker and the South Park guys together. A very underappreciated movie.
You know what, I gotta rent that because when I looked at the trailer, I'm like,
that looks fucking stupid.
And then a comedian that I respected sought and told me it was hilarious and it
was a good movie. And uh, I'm going to rent that. I'm gonna rent that fucker.
Uh, speaking of which,
I finally saw Miller's crossing and the end and I got to admit, uh,
John Turturro is fucking unreal and that movie, God damn it.
That was a good fucking movie. Um, all right, last thing.
Last thing for this week's underrated list is rage against the machine.
This guy says, in my opinion, the best band in the past 20 years. Wow.
And for all the shit that's going on in the world now,
their music was way before its time.
That original album is genius from start to finish.
My only complaint was when I saw them at Randall's island last year.
It was rage against the machine brought to you by rockstar energy drink.
That upset me as well. It should as well it should, but you know something.
That's what happens after a while. After a while,
you get into middle age and you're like, you know what?
At some point I'd like to sleep on a bed. I'd like to have a fucking couch.
And you know what, I drink rockstar energy drink. It tastes good to me.
So if they want to fucking finance the Goddamn for what do I care?
I mean do they have eight year olds putting rock star drink into fucking coke
cans over in Thailand? Cause if that's the case, I want support it. Okay.
But if it's somebody used to build fucking,
I don't know where the fuck I'm going with this. Anyways,
I want to thank everybody for listening to my podcast and like I said,
if you're new to my page,
which I keep saying because I w I'm hoping I have some new people with the new
special out. Um, I do one of these every week to give you a laugh.
At the beginning of the week I answer questions people send in their underrated
overrated lists.
I'm trying to get an a new list going because I'm starting to think that that
one is a and it'd be got, I think we've pretty much handled it at this point.
Um, keep sending those in. But if anybody wants to start a new list,
please by all means, because, uh,
I do not have creative control over the podcast.
If you want to switch the direction of it,
just send me a funny fucking email that spins me off.
I'll babble about something else.
Maybe somebody else will add to it and that's how it happens. Huh?
Isn't that interesting? All right, so this week coming up, I'm going to be a,
I'm actually doing a college gig at a with Charlie Murphy and a Umass Amherst in
Boston. Now it's a private show.
So that's only for students unless you somehow wink, wink,
figure out a way to sneak in, which you didn't hear here,
which of course you did because now it's the podcast.
I don't advocate doing that.
I don't advocate putting on a baseball hat and looking like you're of college
age and trying to just sort of walk a walk in with the rest of the students.
I do not advocate doing that. Okay. Don't do that.
That would really make me upset. All right there. I'm in the clear now. Um,
and the following week, September 11th through the 11, 12, I think the 13th,
I'm going to be at the punchline in San Francisco and the weekend after that,
uh, what's 11 and seven 11 and 17,
18 1920 and 21 I will be at the funny bone in,
uh, Richmond, Virginia.
I'll be vigil visiting my buddy sludge out there on the radio and uh,
I'll be performing right down there at the mall,
right across some Dick Sporting goods. Hi. You like that,
right back down to earth. One hour special. I'm on top of the world.
Two weeks later I'm performing across some addicts in Richmond,
Virginia as a fucking reality slap for you. Um, and that is it.
And the new DVD. We'll be out of this special on September 16th.
And I will be selling that fucker at all my shows and all the autographing
autographing it.
And if you buy it and he just want to come to one of my shows and bring it up to
me and you want me to sign it, I'll sign the fucker.
Cause I appreciate you buying him. And that is it.
And for those of you who want to know what the extras are on it really quick,
uh, I have the Philadelphia rant is one of the extras,
the classic cell phone footage from the show in Camden,
New Jersey where I got booed in front of all those people.
Everybody knows what it is. So that I've got that on there.
I got the uninformed one where I had the,
on my radio show where me and Joe got in a huge argument and then we ended up,
we tried to settle it with a drum battle. And, uh,
then I got some other footage of me just going around to the New York clubs,
talking about different horrific sets that I've had over the years,
just telling the stories. So ton of extras and all that bullshit.
And now I'm done babbling. Thank you so much for listening.
You guys all have a good weekend next week.
I actually will do it on Monday on the Monday morning podcast. There you go,
everybody have a good week.
All right, bye.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] before I got to do left
too.
Okay?
Okay.
[inaudible].